tissues weren't the only thing needed
during this is a season three fall
finale the pearsons reveal a lot of lies
betrayals and wild family secrets that
left hook so shook they're doing what
they do best
but guys major spoiler alert ahead so if
you haven't watched go watch it do
yourself a favour then come on back yep
we'll keep the conversation going
let's see how this is us shocked us with
this big reveal I went to a database for
the War Memorial
Nicholas Pearson 46 Infantry his name's
not there he might be dead but he didn't
die here in Vietnam
not into war anyway so the fate of
Jack's brother Nicky is the biggest
shocker of the hit NBC show he's alive
what I mean come on oh my goodness so
here's what we know Dan Fogelman the
Creator told ET back in October it's
fair to say that clearly something broke
in Vietnam for Jack as it relates to his
brother I think it would be borderline
impossible to guess where it's going
because it's very specific
Jack buried a portion of his life when
he came back for more what we're going
to explore this season is what he buried
holes so I have a couple of theories
let's here at court break it down okay
so either Nicky played a death hoax on
his family or Jack already knew and he
wanted his baby brother to die with
honor as a war veteran because we know
that he kind of had an addiction with
drugs yeah that could be it and Jackie
is our superhero right there all right
Superman
exactly so do we think Jack knew Nicky
was still alive let us know all across
social Katie and Toby are having a boy
we love oh my god my fields are on full
alert
but based on the flash-forwards we know
that Kate and Toby are still together
but it looks like Toby's still dealing
with depression which just you know
makes my little heart ache by all of us
you know we're excited to find out like
how things turn out with her pregnancy
and you know maybe what does she name
the baby boy I don't know what you're
thinking I'm putting a bid on Jack I
really hope somehow he gets into their
naming process and I hope that in the
future they have a child that's the big
thing everyone wants to know yeah okay
let's move on to tests because coming
out about her sexuality was a very
emotional scene I mean this is a tear
jerker that we normally get from this is
us I'm really hoping that they you know
continue to make this storyline
something that we can fall in love with
me too are your parents gonna help you
[Music]
very cool laid-back kinda way without it
becoming a thing that's in Randall's
marriage on the rocks I don't know if I
can handle that I really don't I don't
know if I can handle it either they're
my favorite TV couple but it seems like
Randall's campaign is just the beginning
of a sad ending to our favorite TV
couple it seems like in the
flash-forward Beth it's a dance teacher
her assistant has to deliver the message
to test called so no communication with
Randall are they separated there's so
many questions hell I can't if they're
done like I have lost all faith in love
okay they are one couple that we really
want I know yeah attic that's college so
I was there on the way okay yeah we're
all going to see Randall's mother so
lots of dive into until January 15th
when this is us returns here's one of
the things when Beth says Randall's mom
I was really happy a sigh of relief
happened that it was not Beth that was
questionable about her health but are we
sure that it's Rebecca
aka Mandy Moore or is it Randall's birth
mom Laurel coming into the picture right
now remember William who is Randall's
birth father had said that Laurel died
during childbirth but maybe that's not
true I'm so excited to find out I know
like dying right I know is it a family
secret is in another lied this is us
gets us every time every time but we
also want to know do you think Kevin and
Nikki are gonna meet face to face or
what do you think really went down with
Nikki and Vietnam back in the day we
want to hear what you think yeah we have
our theories I met Courtney underscore
teza know and I met Halle underscore
Stephens until next time you got you
covered for your pop culture fix
you
[Music]